check out this map I stole you may think
this is weirdly sexual in nature but
it's actually Minneapolis Minnesota so
we're both right all the pink gunky bits
are places you can't legally build
anything other than a single family home
meaning you can't erect apartment
complexes meaning we are legally
abolishing density therefore
artificially creating scarcity which
drives up housing prices or here take a
look at this one this may look like a
rugby injury but it's actually Seattle
those pink spots that's where
multi-family housing is illegal you can
only build houses there it's illegal to
build anything other than a single
family home and 75 percent 75 percent of
the residential land and many American
cities not duplexes triplexes or God
forbid apartment buildings not buildings
which could house lots of families
thereby increasing Supply and bringing
down prices you can only build houses